[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: After building
an API with Apigee
and sharing it with
developers, there's
still work to be done to
make sure that everyone
has a successful experience.
As an API producer, you may want
to know critical information
like how is my API traffic
trending over time,
when is API response
time fastest or slowest,
and who are my top developers?
The answers to these questions
can help you improve your APIs,
troubleshoot problems,
and make better decisions
for your business.
This is where Apigee
Analytics comes into play.
Apigee Analytics
collects and calculates
a wealth of information that
flows through API proxies.
You can visualize this
data in the Apigee
UI with predefined
analytics dashboards,
as well as custom reports.
Apigee Analytics can help
improve the API experience
for everyone.
This data can help provide
insight to the API team
about how the API
program is doing overall,
how individual APIs are
doing, and how to improve
and debug APIs.
Analytics information
can also be
shared with app
developers, who will
want to know how to improve
their apps to increase revenue.
The operations team can learn
more about traffic patterns
and when to add
back-end resources
or make other adjustments.
And the business owner
can see whether or not
their initial API
investment is paying off.
In other episodes, we learned
how to build an API proxy,
secure APIs with API keys,
and set up a developer portal.
In this episode, we'll take
a tour of Apigee Analytics
and learn how it can help you
troubleshoot customer issues.
First, visit apigee.google.com
to open the Apigee UI.
As you can see, we've already
created some API proxies
and generated some
traffic against them.
In the left Navigation bar,
click Analyze, and then
API Metrics.
This shows you Apigee's
pre-built analytics dashboards
for API proxy performance,
cache performance, error code
analysis, latency analysis,
and target performance.
API proxy performance
gives you information
about the performance of your
proxy over a period of time.
You can see how much
overall traffic you've had,
including whether it resulted
in success or failure.
There's also average response
time in milliseconds.
You can also view analytics
for a specific proxy.
Next up, there's
cache performance,
where you can see the cache hit
rate, the number of cache hits,
and cache response times.
You can also take a look
at error code analysis,
where you can learn about
how many errors occurred
and what types of
errors they were.
Here we have 60 errors that
were 404, meaning not found.
There were also 30 errors that
were 401, meaning unauthorized.
These likely happened
because the caller did not
provide a valid API key.
Now, let's take a look
at latency analysis.
First, select a time
range of the last hour.
We'll select an API
proxy to look at.
Here we can see some
statistics about response time.
At 3 o'clock in the
afternoon, the 99th percentile
was 97 milliseconds, meaning
that 99% of API calls
were faster than
97 milliseconds.
We can also see that
95% of API calls
were faster than
14 milliseconds.
And of course, the
median response time
was just two milliseconds.
You can analyze response
time by the target as well as
requests and response
processing latency.
There's also a Target
Performance dashboard
to see how fast the
back end system is
responding to your requests.
This can help you
understand when
you might want to use caching.
Beyond API metrics,
you can also learn more
about the developers
that are using your APIs.
Under Developers, can
click Developer Engagement.
Here you can see the total
number of developers,
the number of
developers with apps,
and the number of
active developers.
You can also browse details
about individual applications
the developers have registered
using the Developer portal.
Here we have two apps--
one for stackdriver monitoring
and another for ping stats.
For each of these apps, we can
see the email of the developer
as well as traffic
and error statistics.
There's also a traffic
composition section,
where you can take a look
at your top 10 API proxies
by amount of traffic.
In this case, the vast
majority of API proxy traffic
is for ping status V1.
You can also take a look
at your top 10 developers
by amount of traffic, top 10
products by amount of traffic,
and top 10 apps by
amount of traffic.
There's also an
End Users section,
where you can see the
types of user agents
that are accessing an API proxy.
In this case, we have
some cURL calls as well as
some library calls via Postman.
Finally, there's a geo-map
that allows us to see
traffic broken down by country.
Here we can see that
most of our traffic
is coming from
the United States,
but we also have some traffic
from Singapore, Belgium,
and Brazil.
In addition to the pre-built
Analytics dashboards,
you can also create
custom reports.
Here we have a
custom report where
we can see traffic broken
down by application.
If you select an
application, you
can also see the breakdown
of traffic by API call.
You can also expand the time
frame beyond the current day.
If you want to expand beyond
the listed maximum of 14 days,
you can submit a job to
handle report generation
asynchronously in
the background.
You can come back later to
see the results of this custom
report.
As you can see, Apigee Analytics
comes packed with helpful data
visualizations.
One key use case for
these visualizations
is troubleshooting.
Data visualization
is a powerful way
to unlock, compare,
contrast, and assess
the underlying data that Apigee
collects about your APIs.
Perhaps you've recently received
some feedback from a customer
that one of your
APIs is being slow.
Apigee Analytics can
help you figure out
exactly what's going on.
You can check to see if the
slowness is being seen by just
one app or multiple apps.
If it's just being
seen by one app,
there may be a
problem with that app.
You can also look to see if
the slowness is concentrated
in a certain geolocation, which
may suggest a network problem.
If neither of these
is the case, then you
might have a problem
with Apigee and may
want to look at
policy configuration.
It may also be helpful to
compare the average response
time of different APIs
to see if one of them
is significantly
underperforming the others.
And finally, you could
generate a custom report
to visualize maximum latency
time by app and resource.
Thanks for joining us to learn
more about Apigee Analytics--
a powerful tool to
help you visualize
API data to gain
insights that can help
drive business success.
And friends, if you found
this episode helpful,
please click the Like button
and subscribe to the channel.
Cheers.